[Music]
and new at 11 metro announcing a new
unit designed specifically to target
street racing across the valley yeah
there is no secret it is a big problem
on our streets madison kimbrough joining
us near a metro substation after
speaking to some who are ready to see
this program in action madison
street street racing here in the
northwest valley has been a problem for
a long time now and eight news now is no
stranger to reporting on it as you can
see we are here at a metro substation
and metro police has created a new unit
now devoted to stopping these out of
control drivers
we are dealing with these
racing and trick drivers
these intersection takeovers
in our communities and i'm here to let
you know that we are doing something
about it metro hosting their first
tuesday event virtually on facebook
revealing some new ways in which they
are combating street racing across the
valley in the video metro's traffic
division makes it clear that they are
relentless in their pursuit of reckless
drivers and takeovers and in doing so
they've created a new team called raid
racing apprehension and intervention
detail a unit devoted to stopping these
types of acts from happening residents
in the northwest part of the valley say
they have noticed a change in the amount
of speeding and drag racing in their
neighborhood since the start of the year
it's gotten better i have to say because
i you know
if it's happening in other parts of las
vegas i'm very sorry because i do know
what these you know that what their
neighborhoods are going through it's
it's awful it's scary once in a while
you'll hear someone but nothing like it
was while others in north las vegas
still believe there's quite a bit of
work to be done in our area no it has
not gotten any better i'm just hoping
that maybe they can come up with a
solution that can possibly carry over to
the north las vegas police department
and make the streets a little bit safer
for all the people that are out on the
street
and metro also announced a new email
that people can use specifically for
these incidents it's raid
lvmpd.com reporting in the northwest
valley madison kimbrough live local now